[Musique]
oh j'ai commencé le premier voyage téa à
12 ans et demi 13 ans
premier voyage avait 50 francs en poche
je l'air cas chambre j'ai travaillé j'ai
été rencontré des gens j'étais aussi
chez des gens que tu es aussi capté kick
était à châteauroux aussi je suis resté
un peu chez eux puis après quand je me
sentais trop boulet
alors j'allais ailleurs
ça se passait comme ça
très survenue
de trois mois après sur parti j'avais ça
dans le sang c'est je suis tu es parti à
fond puis en partant bon bah justement
j'étais obligé de de provoquer autre
chose
avec tout ce que je connaissais
et aussi avec tout ce que j'avais envie
de
avec ma mythomanie à moi
moi j'ai jamais fait de fugue je suis
toujours parti en disant pourquoi je
tends liberté surveillée il est même dit
au juge s'appelait rêve il m'avait donné
le caporal épinglé avis viendra jamais
appris à lire
assez pour pouvoir m'intéresser à un
livre sans images
je vais pas mauvais fou
mais qu'elle juge unis un juge pourquoi
injuste pour les enfants non mais
pourquoi puisque avait pas de poursuites
puisque lé nom et ensuite vous avez fait
quelques petites conneries avant fois
disons que je trempais l'on dénommé
petits coups comme ça
normal l'ennui
c'est l'ennui qui justifie tout ça je
crois oui
je crois
c'est l'ennui et
l envie de parler le besoin de l'avis de
2,2
pas avoir à trouver des sources je
m'arrêtais ce jour là devant la terrasse
du tourner
car j'avais devant moi deux spécimens
exemplaire de notre époque des pieds à
la tête c'était le beatnik et le minet
taxer toujours 40 balle thon rouge
quoi comment du sucre pas de pirates de
carbone c'est mauvais pour la ligne
[Musique]
nominé partie dans la direction du
drugstore
à son tour le bit nixon à la sur les
routes en
plus probablement vers la contrescarpe
ou la huchette et moi même je m'en fous
comme chaque après midi acheter le monde
et je fais des plages des saisons de
plage effet d un peu tout quand je suis
arrivé jusqu'à les représentants vendu
des des espèces d'écran comme était
devant la télévision pour sa part est
pour que l'écran deuxième plus bas et
[Rires]
c'était
[Musique]
attendu aussi des petits machins les
cafés pour les sur les téléphones de
petits appareils ou en mettait pour
écrire les messages cap en tirait le
machin à paris ça ça y avait un peu de
tout ça
on mangeait fait bon c'était comme ça il
fallait toujours re dire les mêmes
choses quoi je sais pour les aveugles
voilà cette année ils ont fait les
nouveaux ils ont fait des brosses
et à la fin ce qui nous a vécu une
triste on puis à force d'avoir des ports
qui se claque puis le cinéma autour
parce qu'il faut manger et on peut
manger quand quand on a vendu assez
je ne vous dérange pas
bien
entrée
c'est ouvert
qu'est ce que vous voulez
[Musique]
je suivis
c'est yevou
je suis je représente la marque dans
l'état tambour
on voit que ça par tous ces modèles
modèle entièrement automatique super
automatique si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
encombrement minimum
[Musique]
08 et et axes horizontaux porté sur deux
paliers
choses nouvelles
lavage est à 1 version automatique ce
qui augmente de 50% et c'est logique
fléchissait
l'efficacité de la machine
le color l'encombrement de la 08 et
minimum 46 81 60
qui dit mieux sur toute la place de
paris
aucune machine en europe
mais un encombrement aussi peu important
à 0 0
vous êtes attendus
ce moteur
est à deux vitesses
biphasé
c'est pas fait vous avez du 200 m la
région parce que
110 200 va nous changer une maison
assis encombrement minimum
vous n'êtes pas voyageur de commerce non
la 008
enfin si si si la 008 comporte trois
sélections possibles eu lieu de deux si
vous souvenez de la 007 la 007 deux
sélections mais l'upa voyageur de
commerce mais si madame merci j'ai ma
carte
sis
gmac un
nom
une carte qui est donné par la
préfecture de police je ne suis pas
non
il ya beaucoup de films qui ont découlé
d'une certaine expérience comme ça c'est
à dire que par exemple nathalie granger
tu joues un représentant oui et celle ci
n'ait servi marguerite duras valls l'a
desservie au départ elle voulait elle me
dit
j'aimerais faire un clone de la société
économique
alors jeudi un représentant un clown la
société économique quelqu'un qui fait du
porte à porte et qui vend des trousseaux
aux gens qu'ils forcent à signer parce
que qui va en plus chez des gens
sur lesquels il aura une certaine
influence mère au foyer par exemple il
s'amène avec la cravate ont fuit d'un
trousseau la pauvre malheureuse elle
c'est parce qu'elle a signés se
retrouvent à payer les traites pendant
des années et des années pour une espèce
de linge qui reste pas dit ça des clowns
comme ça danse et des criminels et faut
le jouer un criminel et quand ils
arrivent à se déconnecter complètement
dans la 007 c'est parce que pour la
première fois il est tombé sur deux
femmes qui écoutait
alors il n'a pas pu parler alors il a
commencé à
à partir et à faire entendre le silence
aussi et c'est ça là effectivement je
m'en suis servi aussi parce que quand on
fait du porte-à-porte grandi dam des
aveugles savonnette bros ce machin
heureux dire toujours la même chose
sifflé toujours le même hertz
c'était
à
[Musique]
quand j'étais jeune en laborde dans la
ville de châteauroux
et j'allais au cinéma pipi ça me faisait
toujours une émotion de rentrer dans une
salle noire de voir cette petite toile
blanche puis de voir des gens des
montagnes derrière des aventures
et
comme dans la vie de tous les jours je
confie ça je rêvais avec sa marque est
si malgré tout on imite ont fait un peu
ce qu'on voit ce qu'on rêve
quand je travaillais aussi en imprimerie
dans l'imprimerie d'ouvrir la machine
they faire de la musique et
recevant mes
petites feuilles
geste et je partais leurs règles on
voyait tous très bien et c'est peut-être
ça surtout qu'à commencer 1
alors après bon je suis parti
et puis j'ai commencé à dire quand on me
demandais ce que je faisais quand
j'étais
étudiant en théâtre puis j'avais pas
tellement quattro bien raconter je
répondrai par oui ou par non quand les
gens connaissent très bien je suis là je
me plante est carrément
avec un sourire et puis tout a commencé
comme ça on a commencé à déchiffrer le
caligula on a des chiffres est d'aider à
poèmes après j'ai des chiffres et
pirus se faire rare andromaque c'était
vraiment tout neuf pour moi je savais
pas du tout
si c'était du lard ou du cochon on se
demandait de faire
des mots que je comprenais pas du tout
quand sur néron te dit j'aimais
j'idolâtre juni moi je croyais que juni
jaillissait delattre du feu
doit être un amour terry
si la voit sortir du feu prendre je
pensais à ça finalement c'était pas loin
de la réalité
tu as connu l'avait calage gerra il
avait je crois 16 ans il avait déjà
commencé le théâtre
vaguement vaguement il disait qu'il
faisait du théâtre
il était dans un pur
oui comme c'est comme ça qu'on s'est
connus mais enfin je veux dire que j'ai
tout de suite été
interloqué
parce que il est il avait une manière à
lui donc je raconte quelque chose parce
que il est c'était au cours il a passé
une scène de caligula ils sont arrivés
avec deux copains lui avait plutôt l'air
de loudes banlieue de casseurs et
d'apprentis comédiens ils ont passé une
scène et un moment donné gérard était
tellement
montrer comment il est ému une force de
la nature et où il prend son copain ils
le poussent sur la chaise la chaise
s'écroule tellement il était avec moi et
puis toute la scène s'est passée comme
ça avait c'était
c'était insensé parce que il comprenait
peut-être pas tout ce qu'il disait mais
il y avait une telle énergie une telle
force tu vois moi j'avais jamais vu ça
jamais jamais on m'a parlé de gérard et
il jouait à ce moment là une pièce à la
gaîté montparnasse à minuit et je suis
allé le voir et j'ai trouvé très mauvais
mais je me suis dit quand même je pas de
dégâts là j'ai quand même le voir dans
sa loge et on est sortis dans la rue et
hôtels au bistrot il a commencé à parler
et ce qui s'était passé sur la scène
c'est complètement passée là dans la rue
et est aux bistrots
et je vais faire un essai avec d'autres
acteurs et en l'occurrence c'est une
espèce de séance de pêche à la ligne
et alors tout d'un coup il s'est mis à
exister avec une telle intensité avec
cette canne à pêche qu'il inventait qui
n'existaient pas et puis tout d'un coup
c'était un pêcheur à la ligne et en même
temps je pars il y avait toute
l'angoissé du monde contemporain il y
avait une sexualité fabuleuse il y avait
la folie désespoir il y avait la
vitalité
c'était une espèce de miracle vivons
alors je lui engagé immédiatement
pourquoi tu travailles sa
vie de me promener un peu tard pourquoi
ça devrait être au lit l'air frais la
politique aurait dû faire ça plus tôt
j'ai pas trouvé le temps froid tu l'as
pas fait mener de ton boulot
quand est-ce que je te vois frais un
tour quand je pars à peu près plus tard
je cherchais quelque chose à manger on
bouge pas il y aura tous préparés chez
la vieille g2l complète
tant pis
si
y'a personne pour le moi je me suis
débarrassé d'eux
alors
oui il aussi tu deviens pas j'y serai
meilleur que comme tu pourquoi qu'il dit
pas
on y va les mecs
attendre toute la nuit pour rien très
souvent
ils me racontaient des histoires de ses
frères par exemple avait un frère qui
était très affabulateur qui devint cool
arrêté sur un chemin en lui disant
là il faut pas passer le coin de ce bois
parce qu'il ya des rhinocéros
et il m'a dit à ce moment-là les
rhinocéros existait vraiment dans la
campagne de châteauroux et c'est sur ce
genre de réalité là qu'on travaille avec
g1 et
et il a en lui un monde complètement
fabuleux un monde complètement
instinctif qui lui permet d'accéder
immédiatement à l'intelligence quand je
dis immédiatement c'est à dire sans du
tout le média de la culture ni de
l'instruction
il comprend tout tout de suite et par ce
passe temps ce qui fait qu il le
comprend aussi avec le corps et que chez
lui
c'est à dire très intéressant parce que
c'est un homme pratique et vivons et qui
réalise des tas de choses
extrêmement intelligente c'est à dire
chez lui il faut qu'une séparation entre
l'esprit et le corps qui est une espèce
d'idée qui a fait des tas de dégâts et
beaucoup de mal pendant des siècles en
fait et lui est innée et une évidente
démonstration de ce que donne la beauté
d'un être vivant quand y'a aucune
séparation entre l'esprit le corps et
qu'on est intelligent sans être
intellectuel avez vous pas remarqué que
tout est devenu brusquement ridicule
quand nous avons parlé de rognons
flambent et
non par tous comme an plus tôt à mesure
que nous évoquions les rognons flambée
rognon flambée
rognon flambée rognon flamber
et avez vous remarqué pourquoi
avec les rognons flambée tout devenait
peu à peu atrocement ridicule
parler
parce que nous parlions de quelque chose
qui n'était pas visible
parce que nous évoquions quelque chose
qui n'était pas là et savez vous comment
je les ai remarqués
par les
quand vous avez fait ces gestes de la
main il ya 2 minutes et à deux minutes
de ça
peut-être plus
en tout cas qu'est ce que je voulais
dire quand j'ai fait ce geste de la main
quand vous avez fait ce geste de la main
j'ai brusquement été frappé par les
bagues que vous portez au doigt j'ai
pensé en moi même des bagues tient des
bagues
vraiment
des bagues
puis j'ai regardé à nouveau les bagues
et comme ce que je pensais coïncide
parfaitement avec ce que je voyais je me
suis senti un instant si heureux que je
n'ai pu faire autrement que de vous
mettre la boîte de cigares dans la main
et là j'ai senti combien je m'étais
trouvé ridicule a parlé tout ce temps de
rognons flambé
pendant que j'en parlais je n'étais plus
moi-même mes cheveux se hérissaient sur
ma nuque
et quand j'ai vu les bagues
que j'ai pensé des bagues
et que j'ai ensuite jeté un deuxième
regard sur les bagues
j'ai eu l'impression d'être redevenu
moi-même
moi je croyais que vous me rendiez la
boîte de votre plein gré
vous me comprenez
il m'a dit c'était une époque à avant
d'arriver au théâtre où tu parlais pas
aux gens non c'est pas tout non message
parler parce que j'étais trop
je sais pas je vais un petit blocage la
parole était trop émus
et ça se manifestait généralement par
des
des choses physiques
bouscule ou que
voilà et les ailettes me connu qu'on ne
paraît pas maintenant ça a bien changé
puis tout s'est débloqué avec mu c'est
comme la première fois j'ai entendu des
textes de musset
j'avais vraiment envie de lait digne
je croyais qu'ils vivaient encore
tellement
c'était tellement il me parlait
voilà
alors j'ai demandé où il habitait on m'a
dit au canada je suis allé me savais pas
que c'était si j'ai vu sa tombe son sol
c'est quand même ça me semble suffisait
c'était bien j'avais même eu c'est autre
chose que sur une caractères
d'imprimerie que
sur une pierre tombale puis ma foi comme
cette époque là je mets bien les morts
ça encore ça m'a parlé encore non je le
théâtre c'est un moyen de parler aux
autres de se faire écouter les plus
importants sphérique vous parler tu peux
parler tout seul oui mais je parlais
tout seul avant justement mais quand
c'est pour ça que tu pouvais plus parler
des quatorze de parler tout seul
quand tu te retrouves devant quelqu'un
ce que tu dis est trop fort pour quitter
coûte quand tu demandes par exemple la
force de parler du sol et quand tu es
dans une ville où il ya personne tu
connais personne écoute à la fièvre
à la fièvre parce que la route les
angoisses la pluie le soir qui tombe
quand tu demandes à renseignements comme
aussi une bête que la gare par exemple
la gare de mol avec une telle qu'on te
dit
quand tu craches c'est là bas
parce que tu ne peux dire que ça
alors s'il fallait ce que je pourquoi je
pouvais pas rêver à parler c'est parce
que pour la première fois j'avais le
sentiment que des gens lui coûtait
alors après j'ai compris que 1 me en
apprenant les mots que je pouvais
apprendre pour avoir le sentiment de
parler ben on écoutait d'une autre façon
et quand ils ont pris des départs en ce
milieu le fait que l'ue devienne acteur
comment ils ont découvert ça elles n'ont
pas vu l'an passé
ils savaient pas d'abord ce que c'était
je pense que ça
il qu'on croyait pas bien entendu mon
cru un jour quand la diète a ouvert le
poste à midi et ils ont vu que je veux
lancer un assaut de la tête at ease au
c'était d'un boudu sauvé des houches
beaucoup
fait un petit truc pour le théâtre et
puis c'est passé ainsi gérard exemple
puis c'est comme ça qu'ils ont que je
faisais ça
elles disent jamais que j'ai du talent
ça a dit jamais capitale un objet il a
du culot quand même
c'est bien
eu du pot il
connaissait si l'image du temps dont
personne n'avait jamais au cinéma mon
père est allé au cinéma première fois il
a été par les valseuses avec son vélo un
dimanche après-midi à la pole au cinéma
et
la vue les valseuses comme ça puis si
ça lui a plu énormément c'est sa balle
doit pas plus c'est bien marc ela rien
dit à personne cette île-etat n'a jamais
parlé après la cgt marie
noëlle odyssée très bien à pékin c'est
du tonnerre
[Musique]
wiens 28 juin
moi
je suis un
pur sien depuis des mois dans la chaleur
torride je pense à toi
comment tu t'appelles
sais pas les enfants non pourquoi c'est
pas ben sylla
[Musique]
et
il a une manière de faire son métier qui
est insensé
et que je trouve extraordinaire
parce que je les connais bon je dire tu
vois j'ai quand même été pendant cinq
ans dans le métier je sais comment les
autres le font et je vois comment il le
fait lui et ça m'intéresse pas ce que ça
va dans le sens que que je veux moi
alors cette manière insensée c'est quoi
c'est à dire que
tu connais auguste-comte bon il fait
démarrer son manuel de psychologie
expérimentale en disant on ne peut pas
être
à la fenêtre trèsor regarder passer dans
la rue
là gérard hip hop
voilà et c'est ce que devrait faire un
comédien tu vois moi je crois que c'est
le propre du comédien mais ou bien ils
se regardent trop passer dans la rue
et j'oublie d'y être ou bien c'est le
contraire et il se perd 2 dans la rue
c'est là ou non alors que lui c'est
vraiment la corde raide tout temps que
tu vois il échappe pas d'ailleurs
dans un temps il tombe
c'est que j'aime ce travail
d'équilibriste la chute c'est quoi de ne
pas lâcher quand ils restent dans la rue
c'est quand il oublie de regarder
j'aime bien il y en a beaucoup qui
m'intéressent messieurs gérard ça
m'intéresse tout particulièrement parce
que
parce qu'ils feront l'interdît de plus
près voilà et l'interdît m'intéresse
l'interdît c'est à dire à l'interdît bon
tu sais ce que ça veut dire non mais sur
lui spécifiquement ces quads interdite
c'est à dire qu'il est toujours à la
limite à la frontière il est temps marc
gillet il va très loin il va très loin
dans le
crois que c'est lui qui va le plus loin
je crois que le point culminant a été
atteint avec le film de faire ici parce
qu alors là vraiment je crois qu'il a
touché l'extrême limite que plus loin
c'était trop loin
c'est utile bord de la soul c'était le
oui oui oui il ya eu des points comme ça
pendant les sept morceaux ordonnance 6
des petites mais vraiment dans le faire
hérisser tait
c'était très flagrant et je crois que
c'est là où
il s'est dit si si je ne prends pas de
recul par rapport à ces moments là
je m'en sors pas
alors voilà que vous sachiez votre
m'arrêter prévient au sergent
vous êtes vous complètement
non pas tant je n'aurais jamais pas
beaucoup j'ai dû partir
quand j'ai vu dans les filles j'étais
je savais pas si c'était hier
après je vous jure par la rue
là et je passais le cri enfin
j'ai décidé que c'était le personnel et
personnels de mon fils je choisis
pourquoi il est très grand je rappelle
la bête pourquoi pas beaucoup ça pour
rire
pourquoi elle est très gras et la saveur
très forte au contraire c'est très
sensible
soit un contrat il est très sensible et
très
très facile à être blessé
je pensais que et répondez à mon
personnage effet bien pourquoi
sans lui je pourrais pas faire le fier
que j'ai fait
[Musique]
les racines
racine maurice et de réactions trame de
les
reprendre où il a ressenti ou les
laisser pousser
je laisse pousser mes racines
les longues l'oaci
parce que l'impression que j'en ai des
sérieuses et qu'il faut du temps pour
s'en rendre compte aussi
le seul luxe que j'essaie de m'en
apercevoir
et je crois que je suis vraiment un
paysan
je ne crois pas parole
parce que j'aime simplement la terre
mais j'aime ce qui sort de la terre
j'aime
tout est ce que le travail de la terre
fait le travail du paysan gens parlent
pas
comment dire
ce fin légèrement pour moi c'est très
j'espère que c'est très profond
j'aime me lever avec le soleil me
coucher avec lui
et j'ai même pas l'électricité
jeu j'aime bien le mot
je sais pas j'aime j'aime le leu
leu corde avec la terre dire comment on
travaille comme on fait les bêtes
comment on prenait plus comment donc
comment on emploie son temps avec la
terre et le temps qui passe et des
saisons ça ça je les ai sentis je le
sens dole encore de plus en plus
justement peut-être que c'est un luxe
mais je crois vraiment que c'est
héréditaire
je crois vraiment profondément hérédité
les racines même si on les perd
on les a elles sont toujours là il
suffit de les laisser pousser
ça c'est un luxe c'est vrai et tu
arrives à vivre un ce rythme le pic tué
deux et que tu es vedette j'arrive à
m'en apercevoir d'abord j'arrive à
déclencher
pour que ça pousse
je pense que quelqu'un comme le dd mon
père par exemple qu'est vraiment un
paysan est complètement en dehors de ses
racines c'est justement là le malentendu
c'est comme ça qu'il est dans son monde
à lui qui parle de moins en moins
qui sépare la lui mais s'il pouvait
écrire y ferez des poèmes
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens comme
ça qu ont perdu leurs racines par là
avec la ville avec le travail à l'usiné
les choses la ville est la vitesse avec
qui avec laquelle on vit
[Musique]
plus de monsieur v
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
en 10 900pts eu ton personnage de
paysans italiens il n'est pas gratuit il
vient de quelque chose de profond
complètement profonde
de aussi profond que butane
vous allez maintenant on pouvait prendre
des cours de campagne essayer d'avoir
plus que des amis dont un million en
plus capable de manger une poule
quand je lève des poules
quand je les vois j'aime bien j'aime
bien pensé et j'aime bien l'idée de les
manger si
comme une vache comme un cochon par
exemple les tuer si la fin d'année est
là
comme une pomme ou une cerise une saison
on récolte en attend mais les gens tout
à fait normal
des gens qui ont peur
on ne va pas et qui ne veulent pas
manger ce qu'ils ont vu avant vivent une
erreur
moi je crois à la tragédie je crois à
peine tjv quoi chine
ah l'amour je crois qu'on puisse manger
pas seulement quand on affame quand on a
envie
je ne peux pas m'arrêter dans dents
dans la nuit
quand j'aime c'est c'est bon de manger
[Musique]
mais tu ne fais pas dans une ferme j'ai
pas de femme et j'ai effectivement je
revienne dans une cellule familiale
dougé
dans un petit lieu dit dans berry
4 sa maison qui sont là depuis des
générations
qui travaille toujours de la même façon
c'est-à-dire qui a pas d'eau et l'eau du
puits encore pas d'eau chaude dans le
port
et puis bon bah là donc j'ai eu à
acheter mon petit cochon tranquille au
marché la fois
appuyé de l'âge leur grève puisqu'il est
le tuer quand il fera quand il gèlera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'animal
[Musique]
ne t'a pas eu besoin d'apprendre pour le
film n'avait vient d'apprendre popovici
quand même parce que la jauge est
retrouvée disons j'ai retrouvé le parce
que pour 1900 coms et chacun à chaque ps
a coutume c'est pas du tout les mêmes
comme il le tue par exemple à l'époque
oui de tuer dans le film est né en
1930 par là il avait une espèce dano
comme une alliance avec un pic long
comme ça qu'ils rentraient dans le coeur
et voilà il
tremblait faisait trembler le coeur un
dernier sursaut elle cochon rendait
l'âme
puis moi je découpe et le razel le
découper
en tout cas
parce qu'il ya différentes façons il ya
dans chaque pays a sa tradition pour le
cochon à parme par exemple quand j'en
étais dans le bertolucci j'en ai tué
cinq
les cochons disparaissait au fur et à
mesure toutes les exigences tire avec un
foie
avec un foie de cochon je le découpage
ils ont des idées tri par exemple ça
serve pas pareil que chez nous c'est
celle du plat tri pour faire la peau du
cou la tello tout ça j'ai fait les coûts
la technologie fait des jambons si
la cie une autre façon une autre vente
parce que comme le jambon de parme sèche
dans les montagnes un tout petit peu
plus haut qu'auparavant 13 100 m une
demi heure de paris
là nous dans le berry on le fait avec
des linges du thym du poivre du sel on
le met à sécher sur les poutres de la
cuisine
ça sèche encore
et puis on fait du boudin le sang tout
ça
une fête
donc pas des
[Musique]
villes et ça c'est kas qui perdent alors
déboulé
s'alarme benito
et mai car à
une autre forme de fête et notre forme
d'enracinement à part la terre ce sont
les enfants trois quarts des enfants toi
yaya guillaume ya julie quand quel âge
nous avons cinq ans et demi et des trois
ans et demi ça s'est fait à tous les
enfants d'ailleurs l'époque les mines
j'aime bien d'un
l'oeuf à la vie des enfants
comment ils prennent les choses la
violence avec
comment ils prennent
les vieux aussi les vieux comme les
enfants qui attendent toute la ville et
vieux qui attendent un moment c'est ne
plus avoir envie de vivre pour claquer
j'en ai connu plein de j'aime bien
j'aime beaucoup les vieux les entendre
et ça je trouve ça
intéressant est intéressant c'est
pousser ce palm os
j'aime bien j'écoute ça comme les
enfants les yeux j'étais pas peur ça
l'agonie
pas du tout ce qui me fait peur
justement c'est de çà ne pas savoir le
moment ça ne pas choisir ma mort ce qui
me fait peur c'est de ne pas arrêter ma
vie
mais tranquillement sans sans secousses
j'ai peur de ce que je décide pas
de super mais j'aime bien être surpris à
fond complètement comme les enfants
parce que ça aussi ça fait partie de
l'enfance du diable de décider d'arrêter
un enfant quand ils jouent aux cow boys
et aux indiens
il fait ce qu'il veut et quand il a plus
envie de jouer il arrête
pas pour la vie
pour le métier d'acteur c'est pareil
ouais disons qu'on sent
pour moi moi en tout cas c'est avec
comme ça que je que je justifie parce
que
c'est la seule chose qui m'intéresse les
adultes m'ennuie profondément gêne pas
je n'aime pas les gens quand un costume
aimant nuit complètement les trouve
ridicule ridicule
sont les
qui pue
la
rsp messieurs
formatrice enfin jean-pierre contenant
soir ce professeur
bonsoir
vous êtes beaucoup mieux qu'on dit c'est
vraiment là que nous ne soyons pas
toujours d'accord
dites moi je ne savais pas que vous
aviez été un grand maire de cette ville
dans les circonstances difficiles la fa
qui exigeait beaucoup de courage c'était
pendant l'occupation je crois
beaulieu j'ai fait mon devoir
c'est bien ce que je dis il a fallu bien
il va plus loin
eh bien il transpirait pas comme ça
détendez vous respirez la guerre il y
eut des morts d'accord mais quand même
pas les mots qui vous tracasse
c'est gratuit
[Musique]
ces minima on ait marre de vous
de votre autorité de votre jalousie de
votre corps de votre établissement de
votre mafia
jama non j'aime les vieux les enfants et
les bêtes sénateurs appuient moi moi moi
moi
mais quand je dis moi c'est nous c'est
la cellule c'est la cellule
ce que moi je suis rien sans eux
moi si je n'ai pas elisabeth et des
enfants seraient complètement différent
qui ne l'est pas si tout ça à ce métier
je peut-être chez pas
certainement pas du ltte certainement
pas
j'attendrai
[Musique]